all right let's jump over to this first
story and let's uh we're just chilling
it's friday so we're just having a good
time
i was having a good time until i saw
this tweet from ford fisher he says joe
biden's new anti-terror initiative
classifies anarchist violent extremists
that oppose all forms of capitalism
corporate globalization and governing
institutions which are perceived as
harmful to society as domestic violent
extremists
bravo friends you've done this to
yourself here's what it says
i see categories for of domestic
violence extremists now of course
you can see right here it's kind of
small it says ant anarchist
violent extremist i read that that's
basically antifa i know they didn't say
antifa
but there's an antibody check this out
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
animal rights and environmental violent
extremists
abortion related violent extremists and
that says pro-life or pro-choice
so every abortion doctor yeah they're
not going to enforce it that way
obviously
anti-government anti-authority violent
extremists
and all other domestic terror threats
you know what i love about how stupid
this is
it's like he just they they pulled a
random word out of a hat and then added
violent extremists to it
like what would be the difference like
why wouldn't they just add like um
uh cheese connoisseur violent extremists
yeah well no here's the thing it's a
classic tactic you make everybody a
criminal so that you can selectively
prosecute the people you actually don't
like
but claim that the law is impartial well
to be fair we were criticizing the
federal government on using very vague
generalized language
this is very descriptive language but it
also involves almost everyone
involved in politics and then the list
goes on and on it's even beyond what
what even
ford tweeted about because again there's
animal rights activists
environmentalists
uh anarchists that oppose capitalism and
globalization
pro-life groups pro-choice groups i mean
you have this
huge window that of course could be
interpreted in so many different ways
attached to so many different things and
this is again a part of a larger federal
government initiative that will be using
tens of millions of tax dollars working
with social media companies in order to
track
database spy indict and prosecute people
who they deem
as quote perceived as harmful to society
and when you use that kind of language
you could use that language in so many
different ways again so many different
people
exactly michael bloomberg said that
large sodas were harmful to society and
then we should be able to buy them and
now there's people running to be mayors
of of mayor of new york city that are
actually running on that campaign
this you know this reminds me of imagine
just joe biden's like standing there and
they're like and there's a journalist
like so so uh mr president
your new domestic terror uh uh
initiative
will what kind of groups will you be
going after will you be going after
anarchists he's like oh yes absolutely
right to jail
and what about pro-life groups right
believe it or not jail
and pro-choice groups oh right to jim
yeah like like
pro-life pro-choice anarchist standard
corporate and globalists like
all of them just just shuffle them all
into the gym altogether yeah undercooked
chicken right to jail
overcooked believe it or not jail that's
where that's where we're at i hope you
enjoy the future everybody thanks for
hanging out
yeah welcome to let's talk about this
list yeah
you know it's all hunky dory but yeah
i'm just gonna stew in this for a minute
is that are we really letting it sink in
audience we're just gonna sit here and
be quiet i mean that's it like it's
basically saying everybody but i know
but again i really
it's not going to be everyone they're
going to selectively enforce it oh you
know it's got to be whoever is a threat
to the regime
you know it which is not going to be
anti-vote because they use it
exactly they anticipate the militant arm
of the democratic party uh
kind of like they don't agree with the
democratic party on everything but
there's a reason people like kamala
harris and normie establishment
democrats bail them out of prison right
right right it's because they're really
dumb
and it's like uh here's how you get you
got to imagine antifa
there's like some 17 year old standing
around hunched over picking their nose
and then they're like this is stupid
everyone's stupid
you're stupid and the democrats come up
and they're like
hey look he's stupid you're right he is
stupid and then they go yeah go go
go put on a black mask and throw a brick
yeah i'm gonna put on a black mask and
throw a brick
and that's antifa yeah so this is kind
of a classic tactic though antifa
doesn't have to be completely aligned
with the democratic party the analogy
and i saw this somewhere not about
antifa but just this sort of uh
a joke about the way extremist groups
work you have some guy asking for five
dollars just give me five dollars for no
reason
and then a guy with a knife saying give
me ten dollars or i'll cut you up like
okay they don't agree on the amount
the democratic party is not as far to
the left as antifa is but it's clear
that they make the democratic party seem
less insane by comparison and they help
them achieve their goals because they
frighten people into being subservient i
i i don't
i don't really agree because the media
doesn't talk about antifa like people
don't know about what they do
you know they go around learning about
what they do with the media doesn't
condemn them and i think that sends an
even stronger message everyone knows
these people are out there vandalizing
and hurting people and the only time
anyone makes news is when they defend
themselves against them unless unless
you're a cult member
like there are a lot of people i know
who are just like antifa doesn't exist
and i'm like wait here's joe biden's one
of them of a guy throwing a brick
through the window that's not real do
you see that idea
throwing a brick through a window that
was amazing
there's a lot of people who just don't
uh uh i it's creepy man
i know people personal friends of mine
who i'm just like how did they get to
this point where they're
like insane they're not do what was it
i think luke you posted it maybe you
maybe you didn't it said um
people who uh don't agree with like uh
gender critical gender theory have a
warped sense of reality according new
study or something i post a lot of
pink news names out there a warp sense
of reality it's like
it's projection you turn on you turn on
cnn
you know i love it i love this they were
cnn's complaining today
because uh joe rogan called out brian
stelter
and then someone like brian stelter
retweeted someone saying
you know the entire right-wing
propaganda machine is coming down on you
you know you must be doing something
right or whatever
and i'm looking at that cause i'm like
i'm like brian
the right-wing propaganda machine like
dude you're
you're not the resistance like you're
the empire you know i mean like
you're goliath you work for cnn you're
not the little guy they're
you are the villain also always been
the joe rogan being the right-wing
propaganda machine is hilarious to me i
believe
it was kyle kalinski it was joe rogan
and kyle kalinski talking about that
that's hilarious yeah the right-wing
propaganda machine kyle kalin ryan joe
rogan
it's funny when i first saw when i first
started college
my the first class i ever took at
community college i want to say this was
2013.
my professor was a left-wing guy by the
standards at that time and he was
recommending joe rogan to me i was like
oh this is probably
left-wing nonsense but i tuned in anyway
and i really enjoyed it and i you know i
respected that professor as well
so i i decided to take his advice and
it's just funny to me how maybe three or
four years after that i was hearing
about how
like joe rogan was this far-right
conservative bigot even though initially
my show had been
his show had been recommended to me by
left-wing people it's amazing i mean if
that's the
if that's the ideology that is driving
this joe biden initiative
they can say anarchistic shameless all
they want but
i i thought about this you know like the
far left thinks anyone to the right of
stalin is far right
yes can you go lefter than far left
like what what happened i think you can
make a full circle yeah exactly
in terms of like pac-man dude in terms
of economics you've got
communism total command economy totally
centralized and controlled
and then on the right you have totally
decentralized and competitive
right so i guess that's sort of the
authoritarian libertarian right but i
guess
if you go far to the right you end up
with a lot of control the economic right
is decentralization it's laissez-faire
absolutely and the economic left is
centralization okay
so on the on the political spectrum left
is communist right
is capitalist what if you're like on the
furthest left where you're a total
communist
like is there another because like if
these people think they're centrists no
joke like they post a meme oh i know
where it's like bernie sanders is in the
middle
and then it's like to the left of him is
nothing and i'm like bro you can't be
lefter than that
like you're a socialist you believe the
economy should be under command
authority like
i don't know where you go after that
yeah well it's funny because i remember
people calling
obama a moderate but the thing is it
already is it's already centralized with
the federal reserve yes
helping the big banks make sure that
they never lose make sure that they get
to keep their profits we're already in a
very centralized economy
that they've won cnn is in power
absolutely uh you know
the institutions have been all taken
over the cultural institutions have all
been taken over
every aspect of people's existence is
dominated by this
except for the supreme court and there's
even arguments to make that that has
been compromised by a lot of
establishment elites and we have to
understand what's happening here
i mean we also have to see this from
this window that
you know joe biden's not really calling
the shots there if there ever was an
argument that there was
men in the shadows really running things
it's joe biden being able to speak for
himself
when you see joe biden speak for himself
that is the biggest case you can make
that there's a shadowy group of special
interests behind the scenes that are
really calling the shots
and what are they doing they're passing
these very vast
definitions of their new anti-terrorism
initiatives
they're trying to disarm people and
they're trying to take away more of
their money with
this latest death tax proposal which
would absolutely destroy the middle
class and and
fail people from even inheriting
property in the future in most american
cities
so yeah when you have all of that and
combined together you're like wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on
the the walls are closing in here it's
interesting we did a video on this for
the foundation for economic education
and death taxes and inheritance taxes
actually increase income inequality
because the middle class and lower class
inherit more of their wealth larger
percentage of it than the upper class do
businesses people's houses what whenever
they are passed down to them
part of it they can't keep them because
they have a huge tax burden which is
which is put on them by the state and
now
biden wants not biden the the special
interests behind biden want to increase
that tax burden do you see
when biden was speaking and he
accidentally said libya three times out
of syria
yes in 90 seconds yeah i was just
thinking how funny would it be if like
it's you know biden's in the oval office
and then like someone runs in like the
door swing like barges open and he runs
and he's sweating and his tie is undone
and he slams the fold on the table and
he goes
mr president it's syria with weapons of
mass destruction we must act now before
it's too late
and then bind goes on he picks up the
red phone he goes fire the missiles in
libya
and then like the missiles go flying at
libya and then
fire you know the thing no fire fire at
libya libya
and then lip and the icbms go out and
then th
one guy goes sir did you mean syria and
then the spokesperson goes
he did mean syria and then the missiles
blow up and wipe out libya sparking
world war three
why did america blow up libya and it's
like biden's like
then binds like are meant to do that
oh i said syria come on man
you know you know what i meant you you
push the wrong button what are you doing
and like libya gets wiped out then
france gets mad because a bunch of
french
soldiers were there and then world war
iii and you know libya is already pretty
wiped out because of hillary clinton and
barack obama also very true yeah yes
that is that's true
that's where they have human slavery
that was brought to you by the first
black president of the united states
that literally did it through regime
change and finance radical terrorist
groups in the region that now have a
complete control grid on the immigration
that is going through africa into europe
uh with human traffickers now being
emboldened and enriched more than ever
before
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you